texas governor greg abbott is with us
well first of all
i want to start at the beginning because
you're on the show governor and
and explaining that you were trying to
get child protective services
into these facilities and
your protective services were being
denied access
now the first thing we saw were the kids
in in biden's cages in the overcrowding
now we got allegations of rape how long
did it take child protective services to
even get in and take a look
well the child protective services still
has not been allowed in let me let your
audience know
what exactly happened and that is
yesterday two state agencies
in texas that health and human services
commission as well as the child
protection agency in texas
they each separately received complaints
that included allegations about
sexual assault of a child when i tell
you that no
that those words were not used what was
used instead
was a very specific description about
ways in which children were being
sexually assaulted
where it was happening who was doing it
and the horrific things
that were being done that i cannot tell
you on tv
here's my point and that is the body
administration knows about this they
knew about it yesterday because
we share the information with them and
yet still nothing is happening
and and know also because it's happening
there it could very well be happening at
these other child detention centers so
the bite administration right now
they are now saddled with child sex
assault allegations
and doing absolutely nothing about it
and sean that's exactly why yesterday
i requested that administration shut
down
this location let me tell you something
else sean that's really amazing
because i looked at that location
i did not see any security personnel at
all
there was not a law enforcement officer
anybody else who seemed like they were a
person in charge of or even dealing with
securing this location these could be
very dangerous places
for these kids who have traveled through
mexico who knows what may have happened
to them along the way
only to maybe repeat assaults they were
victims of
on the treacherous pathway to the united
states now you made this
this announcement